hi I'm RIA I'm a pasty producer today as
always I've been challenged to take a
common fate and make it fancy let's see
what we are making fancy today drum
rolls Eagles as you can guess I've never
tried this before but I know about
Eagles because I watched stranger things
what for it's also popular in Japan so I
can probably guess what kind of flavor
it will be my favorite kind of waffle
it's crunchy outside and it's a little
bit fluffy and chewy inside a go seems
like very thin my concern needs a go
will be a little bit drier side look
cute to look like a pancake from cartoon
it's hard it's very crispy it's a little
dry but it'll definitely help I like the
design of it it's cute it's round my
favorite shape it's very thin I like my
waffle a little bit fluffier this is
almost eating cookie back of the box
have some suggestions like breakfast
sandwich I think we should make it more
fancy I've got some great ideas so as
always I'm excited to make it fancy all
right here's what I got bananas penny
cream butter and egg from the pantry I
got milk vanilla extract cream of tartar
sea salt powdered sugar sugar cornstarch
bourbon and brandy double alcohol all
right let's get started
make it fancy so first separating 4x
oh maybe today it's today always crack
the egg on a flat surface
one of my pastry chef taught me how to
crack like up against each other this
way you don't make a mess on the surface
like I did I'm going to use egg whites
later and now I'm just going to use egg
yolk 3/4 cup sugar 1/3 cup of corn
starch and 4 cups of milk turn on the
heat to medium high you have to keep
whisking until it bubbles about 10
minutes you don't want any lumps okay so
it looks great reduce the heat to low
and whisk another minute or so it's got
much thicker quarter teaspoon of salt
one teaspoon of vanilla two tablespoon
of butter
whisk it until butter is completely melt
is oome something with waffle oh okay Oh
ruffles it's kind of cute can be a cute
dog night butter is completely melted
transfer to class oh you want to strain
this because you want to have a similar
thing put plastic kind of touching the
surface so it doesn't form any skin on
the surface this is a little hot right
now so you want to make it room
temperature and then keep in the fridge
and we are moving on to next step it's 1
cup of sugar quarter cup of water and
you just start once just make sure
everything is kind of wet turn on the
heat to high medium once you start
cooking don't touch it because it's
gonna crystallize so you just want to
heat until the sugar turns like a copper
color so the caramel looking good a nice
color and you and a ton of the heat and
add 1/2 cup of cream do this off the
heat because once you are the cream it
bubbles up
and you're gonna whisk quarter cup of
butter when you are making caramel a
home be careful because it's really hard
to finish this step I'm adding one
teaspoon of sea salt one teaspoon of
vanilla 2 tablespoon of bourbon I
personally don't drink whiskey or
bourbon but this makes very nice bourbon
caramel so that was fast of our two
alcohols check bourbon caramel is ready
set this aside and let's move on one cup
of heavy cream 2 tablespoons of powdered
sugar when you are whipping cream with
sugar powdered sugar works better
because it's melt faster and as always
I'm whisking by hand alcohol and hand
with the cream no worry I like soft peak
but today I'm going for stiff peak okay
looking good we got nice stiff peak and
it's time to move on and it's at a time
we are preheating over 375 bake this for
seven to eight minutes until golden
brown and it's nice and toasty and for
this we wanted to use them all so we
don't have time to just cook you know to
at the time using 1/2 cup of sugar 1/2
cup of water bring this to a boil just
to melt the sugar 2 tbsp or brandy and
that was our second of two alcohols so
check check sure guys completely melted
so I just wanted to brush some syrup
because I find a go is a little bit dry
so I want to make it let's try and add
some good adult flavor all the AYGO are
brushed with syrup we are going to save
this for later one cup of sugar 1/2 cup
of water heats up until 240 cm high
while I'm waiting I'm going to whip egg
whites to soft peaks adding 1/2 teaspoon
of cream of tartar
I'm using room-temperature egg whites
because it's whips fast and temperature
it's 240 adding into the egg whites so
you want to pour hot sugar syrup into
egg whites in a city stream so the sugar
evenly distributes to the egg whites
another visual cue if it's ready like
whites become very glossy it's nice
stiff peak consistency of toothpaste
okay we made a beautiful Talia meringue
and we are getting cross we made a lot
of components today so let's recap
whipped cream Italian meringue pudding
bhavan kernel pink brandy syrup soaked
Eggert and I have my secret weapon torch
but we're gonna use it later now we're
gonna start with bananas I want to make
this a go perfectly fit my Bissell's I'm
going to trim a little bit and if you
don't have smaller vessel like this you
can use any kind of container and I
chose this because I want to show
beautiful layers and I'm going to use
two Eggos per container first layer its
pudding and layer - it's a go layer 3
it's bananas you want to make an even
layer so you don't want to to open up it
and caramel and whipped cream to make
sure they have a nice beautiful layer
and another egg oh and more pudding next
we got bananas have you seen how monkey
peel banana
yeah I peel banana from here but monkey
peel banana from here and it's easier
shout out to monkey and more camel and
Italian meringue right and are we gonna
touch it
oh nice beautiful and we are done
[Music]
Haidee welcome back to make it fun see
you for having me again
I love you a t-shirt did you get it oh I
just got it at shop make it fancy calm
make you fuzzy duck calm yeah it's shop
your own website what do you see what do
you think I'm seeing like a trifle and
then like it's given me some Baked
Alaska vibes did you put this on fire
yes yes you tell I wish I'd see my it's
my friend that's so scary
can you guess what I made a mess I
really can't
it's gonna I don't know it's hiding the
tightening yeah mmm really good
yes is there any booze in this always
alcohol
have you ever done triple alcohol no yet
was it like a pancake close well okay
what Walmart I'm thinking it's an egg oh
it's like it's like yeah yes yeah you're
just hurting your said genius I like it
it is so fancy like you could really see
use service to a queen Oh King I think
Kate Middleton would eat that it's just
a bit of it what about Elizabeth she's
the queen she's the queen yeah I would
love to go hot power oh my god make it
fancy
this is a very fancy trifle travel
travel travel trifle driver a British
accent is make you fun make it fancy
that's Australian not fun let's make it
fun make it fancy make it fancy
[Laughter]
[Music]
you